Most of the stuff which fills our universe
is completely invisible to us.
Visible matter,
the kind that we and the
stars are made from,
the kind that radiates light,
is not what's normal.
The majority of the energy-matter
content in the universe
is something that we call dark energy.
After dark energy, the second-largest ingredient
is something that we call dark matter.
It gravitates exactly like visible matter.
But it's completely unlike us
in every other way.
We believe that 80 percent of the normally
gravitating matter in the universe
is dark matter.
We believe that every single galaxy,
or almost every single galaxy,
lives inside of a dark matter halo.
And at least, at first approximation,
light seems to go right through
it, so we can't see it.
It's invisible, maybe transparent, maybe clear.
And we, the luminous matter,
we are the cosmic weirdos.